all right if I can't get into Comicon by
myself
I'll ask for help from my little friend
ha ha ha
okay here's the deal go over there
he activate the alarms a locked door
then hey you're gonna do the rest of the
plan he's not coming back is he what you
have to do to get into that place
Jess I'll just take a stroll and check
out this house
TV I like TV in fact I once needed we're
projecting that on 15 even a 0 by nd
revolution isn't that to show without a
world without electricity
a world without electricity speaking of
electricity I could use a little
pick-me-up right about now anybody have
an extension cable anybody you were I've
got to find someone that someone is out
to get me into the car people let me
back play qualy but then you go up no
one takes your calls are too far your
detail my whole body of a brother out
like that's not cool don't forget who
has one grams of human hair - gasps same
to you thanks for nothing
and now there's a sight for sore sensors
I just did
she'll know what to do if she can tune
in no one can
all right let's go did I mention your
Google glass makes you look like a cute
sidewalk let's grab a can of oil mirror